from Christmas to New Year's you can
ring in the New Year at PT's with a lot
of great food drinks and other
celebrations here to tell us what they
have planned for New Year's Eve and the
recovery the next day is Vincent Russo
and so thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me and thanks for
bringing props it's really getting us in
the spirit you guys have a lot going on
tell us what you have planned for New
Year's Eve yeah before we get to New
Year's Eve we're running our pretty
sweet giveaway where we'll be giving
away our golden entertainment suite at
T-Mobile arena
for a Vegas Golden Knights game in
January so yeah so you can stop into any
PT's Sierra gold Sean Patricks and ask
your bartender how you can win that is
not a great way to start the new year I
love that you guys
you guys also grab a drink some food
what do you have going on yeah so for
New Year's Eve aside from our amazing
happy hour from 5 to 7 P.M we'll be
doing uh 10 P.M to midnight all you can
drink sparkling wine for ten dollars a
person ten bucks a person that's a great
deal and then to ring in the New Year
we'll do a complimentary champagne toast
you can't go wrong with champagne and
you know you need some food though to go
along with your drink so we'll get to
the Burger in a second but on New Year's
Eve full menu anything special for that
full menu we have these party favors I
really just want to bring in uh a good
end to the year and open up the new year
yeah so and you can open up the new year
which is also known I think is National
Bloody Mary day hangover day probably
all packed into one so what do you guys
have going on for New Year's Day so we
have a five dollar Bloody Mary uh it's
an absolute Bloody Mary and then we have
our hangover Burger uh it's two quarter
pound patties uh bacon crispy onions
lettuce tomato rpt signature sauce uh
topped with a sunny side up egg on a
brioche bun served with fries for
fifteen dollars it looks delicious and
after that two hours of wine the night
before you're gonna need that's perfect
what I love about pts is you can't drive
down the street for more than a mile
without seeing one so you guys have so
many locations across the city is this
happening at every location or where can
people go all 62 taverns in Clark County
and we'll be opening more taverns next
year so hopefully uh when I'm standing
here next year we're talking about more
than 62. yeah you guys have a lot going
on and also uh happy hour all the time a
great happy hour so you have that to
look forward to in the New Year anything
else that people should know before they
come into a pts I mean it's just always
a good time yeah I mean if uh if you go
to
www.ptaverns.com you'll see all of our
promotions and you can get a jump on any
of the great prizes we're giving away
well Vincent thank you so much this is
going to be a party be sure to go to the
website there will definitely be a PT's
close to you and cheers to 2023